hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
lc3 associated endocytosis starting
against neuro inflammation and neuro
degeneration i am michelle ashton of lab
roosts and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by built to be biotech to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now put that today's
speaker dr. Bradley L Heckman spelling
and immunology at st. Jude's Research
Hospital in Memphis Tennessee for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen after has many now begin
your presentation
well Michelle thank you so much for the
for the wonderful introduction and to
all of you out in cyberspace watching
this webinar I really wanted to thank
Milton II for the opportunity to share
some of our work that we're doing in the
lab with all of you today
some work that we think is is a very
important to the field of neural
inflammation and neurodegenerative
research as well as leading to this
novel discovery of this pathway lc3
associated endocytosis and hopefully by
the time we are done today for those of
you who are not directly in the field
you will have better understanding of
the importance of these pathways in
neuro degeneration and neural biology as
well as the immune response in the
central nervous system so prior to
getting started I do just want to clear
up that I have no conflicts of interest
or any financial disclosures to declare
today and this research is all for the
most part been accepted in there's some
new research that we will show at the
very end some new data about how this
pathway leads to future scientific
endeavors so we really started in the
lab with this this central question we
wanted to know the role of the atashi
machinery in neuro inflammation and in
the lab we have a lot of different areas
of research that we focus on were multi
modality lab if you will we study cell
death processes we study immune function
and T cells all the way through to these
new functions of the etaf Aegina shi
nuri in these non-canonical uses of the
itaku g proteins and regulating not only
immune responses but at the level of
cell biology and biochemistry as a whole
and we've really presented this question
because of an interest in the context of
neuro inflammation and we know that
neuro inflammation is a characteristic
trait of almost every neurodegenerative
disease such as Alzheimer's Parkinson's
disease but also plays a role both a
positive role and also a negative role
depending on how its regulated in the
context of immune defense in the brain
as you'll see momentarily so we really
wanted to answer a big question that's
outstanding in the field and that is how
does this process of neural information
is actually
and really we are learning more and more
every day about this go we still have
very big questions and the regulation of
these processes in the brain is not very
well understood so that brings me to the
next point of why actually study at otha
G and the associated pathways of this
itas with your machinery especially in
the context of the brain and we know
that you know if we look at diseases
such as Alzheimer's and Parkinson's
typically these diseases or age-related
conditions and we know from some elegant
work from multiple labs that the atashi
genes typically in humans as well as
other mammals decrease with age and we
know that they they are further
decreased in the context of brains from
alzheimer's patients so there's a
becomes this deficiency in the etapa
gene machinery at the genetic level and
we also know that etaf adji has very
nicely described roles in the context of
neuronal function labs such as David
Rubenstein the Ralph Nixon have shown
great work along the lines of Vltava G
and neurons and another context in the
brain and we know that defective etosha
G has been proposed as a driving force
for amyloid beta pathology so this
protein that is a causative factor in
Alzheimer's disease we know that with an
impaired autophagy mechanism in neurons
that this leads to a defect a defective
clearance of amyloid generating on a
staging vacuoles and we also know from
work in our lab and now others as well
that the use of the etapa G machinery in
this process that we call LC 3
associated phagocytosis which you'll
learn about momentarily is a is a is a
major pathway and actually regulating
inflammatory immune activation or what
the lack thereof depending on the state
of these etapa G machinery proteins and
genes
so to start the story really have to
tell you a little bit about especially
with a broad audience about etaf adji
and about this process of lc3 associated
phagocytosis that we refer to as lap
that's where this whole project really
got started and hopefully as we progress
through the presentation you will see
how lap leads into this discovery of lc3
associated endocytosis which we refer to
this land though so if we start at the
very beginning we know that you know
canonical the top is you which just
recently won the Nobel Prize for its
discovery is is a intracellular pathway
in reality so we're performing these
membranes these nascent structures as
you can see where it says initiation up
here on the left side of the screen this
this Auto [ __ ] ofor is being formed and
it's a membrane structure that
ultimately will be destined to engulf
cytosol like cargo and organelles and
there's a there's there's basically
three component machineries to this to
this process of itas deactivation and
completion and that is governed by an
initiation complex containing the serine
threonine kinase EUL k1 as well as to
200 and other proteins that will lead to
the activation belief through
phosphorylation of backward one of this
pi3 kinase complex anchored by the pi3
kinase VPS 34 and this p i3 kinase
complex is distinct from the one that
some of you are in the immunology field
will we'll know in other context and it
actually produces a very unique lipid
species phosphatidyl inositol 3
phosphate pi/3 p and as you can see that
pi/3 P is is produced within this
membrane there's growing on a [ __ ] or
if you will and that pi/3 p is an
essential lipids species that will end
up being a substrate for the conjugation
of a microtubule associated protein LC 3
in LC 3 has a variety of roles but for
today's talk really all that you need to
know is that lipid ated LC 3 so LC 3
that it becomes attached to those pi/3 p
substrates in the membrane will
facilitate the maturation and ultimately
fusion of the non-auto phagosome with
the lysosome in this pant this is
actually a family of proteins but again
for today we're just going to call it LC
3 and after you have pi/3 P production
by this ATG 14 beckylyn 1 EPS 34
containing pi3 kinase complex then you
have this next complex in sequence that
is what we call the ligation machinery
and this is a ubiquitin like system that
can comprise of a variety of the top G
proteins the big ones that are most
familiar in the field are ATG 5 and ATG
7 and this complex is the one that is
responsible responsible for actually
processing LC 3 to put it and stick it
onto those pi/3 P residues in the
membrane those lipid species in the
membrane in comparison to canonical
Atossa G in-lap we're not utilizing
intracellular cargo or organelles or
defective organelles we're actually
targeting substrates that are
extracellular and those that will bind
receptors on the cell surface such as
dying cells I'm as in particles which
are a yeast particle and in other things
and through that comes through a
ligation of surface receptors that leads
to the engulfment through a traditional
phagocytic pathway and in contrast to
normal phagocytosis which all of that
machinery is required for laughs now we
just add on this protein lc3 in a very
similar fashion to what occurs in the
toffee and what you can see here in this
in the diagram on the right is that
unlike canonical atashi laughs does not
utilize this initiation complex of you
okay wanted to 200 it's completely
dispensable four-lap furthermore what
you can see is there's a distinct pi/3 P
or pi/3 carnea complex excuse me in lab
compared to canonical ecology and in
this complex we still have Becklund one
in the pi3 kinase VPS 34 but we've
replaced ATG 14 with another protein
it's a run domain can run domain
containing protein that we call Rubicon
and Rubicon has been implicated in as an
inhibitor of canonical etaf regime and
we really met that work is still
slightly debatable but what could
possibly be occurring there is that
Rubicon is functioning to direct
components the other components that are
used in both both
to Aegean lap away from the atashi
pathway to be utilized in this unique
pi3 kinase complex in the lap pathway
another thing that is dissimilar between
the tapa G and lap is the fact that lap
requires the production of reactive
oxygen species or Ross and that occurs
through this NADPH oxidase NOx to where
a lot of where of course that is totally
dispensable for at offer G and then the
conjugation of once pi/3 P actually is
produced and again placed into this
phagosome instead of the Otto phagosome
once it's placed in this this phagosome
that has cargo internally then the same
machinery the ligation machinery it's
the same complex that is used in
canonical Ataka G is able to attach this
LS process and attach this LC 3 molecule
and then that will also facilitate the
fusion and degradation of this vesicle
with the lysosome so they are very
similar but very unique processes at the
same time and as I mentioned earlier the
stimulation of these visa these two
different processes whether it's toxic
to your lap are very different we know
in canonical etapa g nutrients stress
and nutrient starvation and interest
other stress signals as well as growth
factor deprivation typically activated
variety pathways including in TOR as
well as amv kinase and these will lead
to the activation of that uo k 1 to 200
complex that's all canonical as hostages
activate in comparison lap is activated
again through the ligation of surface
receptors such as FC receptors Tim 4 in
the context of a pop tot excels and when
that cargo is internalized now we know
from recent work that Rubicon is
recruited to that developing phagosome
or membrane first before the rest of the
components of the pi3 kinase complex and
other machinery however the the
signaling and the events that lead to
that recruitment are still unknown in or
something that we're currently working
on as well as other labs and it would be
interesting to see how that actually
occurs but we know that that happens and
that is the activating signaling
four-lap compared to canonical itas is
so very distinct at the level of
activation
and what we know that lap is that it
actually is important for maintaining
amino silence and what I'm showing here
is just a schematic of a process that we
call a Pharisee of Pharisees I toast
which is the clearance of a dying cell
and we know from work in our lab as well
as others now that when macrophages that
are going to clear this dying cell have
the LAT pathway intact they produce an
anti inflammatory response so there's
there's no immune consequence of that
process and they that's characterized by
interleukin 10 production which is an
anti inflammatory modulator and as well
as others including tgf-beta in
comparison when you have a deficiency in
the LAT pathway within the macrophage
the internalization or phagocytic uptake
of this dying cell and other cargo as we
know now leads to the pro-inflammatory
cytokine activation of aisle when beta
TNF alpha il-6 and others and this will
promote an actual immune response so
what we know thus far is that Lapp
actually facilitates regulating this
inflammatory activation in macrophages
as well as other monastic cell types so
that brings us to this real question of
back to this idea of neural inflammation
and neuro immunity so we know that these
processes of Vltava G and now Lap are
important in regulating function of
peripheral immune cells such as
macrophages but we were really still
interested in this question of neural
inflammation and the reason is is
because the neuro immune system is a
privileged site if you will the brains
of privileged immune site typically
unless you have massive disease and
blood brain barrier permeability by
virtue of that blood-brain barrier
you basically prevent the influx of
peripheral immune cells and peripheral
modulators into the brain and it's
governed mostly by this resident immune
cell in the central nervous system
this is the microglia cell and as you
can read here I'm not going to go
through this into my step but microglia
are not only the resident mean cell the
central nervous system but they do
account for anywhere from 15 to a 1/4 of
the cells in the CNS they come from a
very different lineage than those
necessarily a peripheral macrophage or
tissue resident macrophage but there are
very much a macrophage like cell that
can phagocyte
endocytosed and activate inflammatory
responses they also aren't able to self
renew and the proliferation of these
cells in response to a stimulus is
restricted to the central nervous system
and hopefully what you can appreciate on
the left side of the screen is that
these cells are typically in a what we
call a ramified state so they have
processes that are surveying the
environment around them and upon
activation these cells retract those
processes and they basically become a
ball if you will recall that in amoeboid
morphology and that will be important
for some of the data under so later
so microglia have this duality of
function in the fact that they can be
activated down for the lack of a better
term this in one polarization or in two
polarization so in one being pro
inflammation into being anti
inflammation and we know that when
they're polarized down this m-1
pro-inflammatory type that can be a
neurotoxic function now in most contexts
in the normal functioning mammalian
brain this is actually a thing that is
necessary you need to be able to have
cells that polarize down the
inflammatory pathway because they serve
some specific immune functions and what
happens is when these cells become there
that inflammatory response of those
cells becomes basically unchecked
unregulated or dysregulated that is when
we can have a neurotoxic function of
those microglial cells but if it's an
acute inflammation in response to a
pathogen for example it's a very
beneficial process comparatively
microglia function and a lot of
homeostatic processes including neuronal
and synaptic pruning as well as just
overall maintenance of the central
nervous system and those functions
typically are characterized by this M -
like polarization of the cells and non
inflammatory polarization characterized
by Isleton production and others and
this provides a neural protective
function so they have this duality of
function and both both pathways can be
activated in a positive manner however
if the one of inflammation is left
uncontrolled
that can cause significant issues as
you'll see we also know that microglia
can undergo this process of reactive
micro gliosis
this is what on what I'm referring to
when we have you know an activation
that's inflammatory
such as you know an air pollution a
trigger such as amyloid as you'll see I
can activate microglia and if that is
not dealt with these neurotoxic factors
inter neurons and the neurons will
function in a feedback loop basically
seeing is sending what we call help me
signals back to microglia to try and
remedy the situation and this can become
a vicious cycle itself propelling it we
call that reactive micro bioessence so
if we go into the context of neuro
degeneration and these neurodegenerative
diseases we know that protein
aggregation is also a very very
well-known characterization of these
these particular set of conditions and
in the context of what you'll see today
that would be beta amyloid and we know
that those those those accumulations of
amyloid for example lead to neural
inflammation in the human brain and
Alzheimer's and that neural inflammation
can lead to further immune activation so
we ask the question does lap in
microglial cells actually regulate their
activation and if it does how does it do
this so the first thing back to before
we start on the data the first thing I
want to show you here is that we're
using a form of amyloid beta the 142
peptide it's a cleavage product of
amyloid precursor protein and this is
one of the most ferro toxic forms of
amyloid beta and is one that is accounts
for the majority of amyloid amyloid
content if you will in amyloid plaques
in Alzheimer's disease patients and we
know when this this particular peptide
is cleaved it's monomeric and it rapidly
due to its structural characteristics
rapidly oligomers and then will
eventually form amyloid fibrils that
become these amyloid plaques and I think
most of using the general public have
heard of at one point in time
and we know that those plaques and those
oligomers are inducing reactive
microglia OSIS both in mouse models as
well as in human disease and that's just
recapitulated here
so the first question we really had to
ask is lap even activated in response to
amyloid are we going to see lc3 being
placed on vesicles that contain amyloid
or not and the the answer to that
question is we did absolutely so what
we're using here is a microglial cell
line this is a mirroring microglial cell
line it have been CRISPR modified to
either be deficient in etapa G at Apogee
and lap or lap specifically and what you
can see here is that whenever we have a
deficiency in lap these ring structures
of LC 3 in green are no longer
surrounding or attached to these
vesicles containing the reddamma bulling
if we if we delete genes that are
required for canonical etapa gene
there's no change in that localization
so it appears to be a totally distinct
process from that of canonical etaf adji
but is that sufficient is that that an
inability to conjugate LC 3 to those
vesicles enough to induce an
inflammatory response of those microglia
like we see with dying cells for example
and macrophages in the periphery and
again the answer to that question was a
striking yes if we take primary
microglia from cells excuse me from mice
now that are either heterozygous in
white for Rubicon or the bottom one
excuse me for the typo are actually
deleted for Rubicon this required
protein for laughs it's dispensable for
conical atop the G so these might still
have a tossa G if we take microglia from
those mice and we we treat them with
this neuro toxic amyloid what we see is
it both the message level on top as well
as the protein concentration on the
bottom we can see that there is an
exacerbation of inflammatory cytokines
including TNF alpha aisle one theta in
aisle six when we do not have the
ability to conjugate LC 3 to the
specific compartment containing amyloid
furthermore we can take that a step
further and this is going back into
primary cells now from a multitude of
genotypes and what we can see is that in
the red bars those are genes that are
required for esophageal and if we
abrogate those genes we can see that it
really has no effect on the
pro-inflammatory cytokine production
however if we if we delete genes that
are specifically required for Laughs or
those that are
for both the toffee and lap in the green
excuse me in blue bars we can totally
see that we now have an exacerbation
inflammatory cytokine production
so laughs appears can be protective
against beta-amyloid induced
inflammation but is there an actual and
vivo relevance this if there's not
wealth when we discovered something okay
in the context of cells so to answer
this question regarding and in vivo
relevance for laughs and these pathways
that we just described and showed you in
the context of cell culture we really
wanted to utilize a model of Alzheimer's
disease to interrogate this and one of
the best models for that is the 5x bad
model and real brief briefly this model
is characterized by five different
mutations that we call familial
associated disease mutations from
familial Alzheimer's disease and they
they occur in the genes mo a precursor
protein as well as percent worm one and
we took this animal and we crossed it by
our models of lab deficiency as well as
at oxygen deficiency to really
interrogate this question of them vivo
relevance and I want to make note real
quick because the data that you're going
to see soon is is pretty characteristic
of this 5x fat model or what we know
about the 5x fat model is that it
replicates a lot of facets of human
Alzheimer's disease in the mouse model
including amyloid deposition which
typically starts with a few sporadic
amyloid deposits around four months of
age and slowly builds out to a year plus
with actual plaques forming it does have
a little bit of tau pathology but
typically the hyper phosphorylation of
tau which you'll see soon does not occur
to to an extent that's comparable to
human disease and there is a very mild
neuro degeneration once the animals are
aged and you know that will be important
for the for the slides that are upcoming
so the first thing that we wanted to do
is to profile these animals and if we we
just look right here and this is the
hippocampus which is one of the first
sites of amyloid deposition in
Alzheimer's disease you can see in red
amyloid beta is starting to deposit at
four months of age these maestra four
months old when they were analyzed and
you can see that in basically wild-type
mice in the top left here or a tappa G
my deficient mice this so they're
specifically deficient in top of G on
the right really no difference in their
amyloid deposition however what we saw
was striking we saw that if we delete
proteins that are required genes are
required for
we now see that we have a massive
massive just exacerbation in the
accumulation of amyloid at four months
of age in these models it's making the
ATG five here that's knocking out Toth
Aegean lap as well as the 204 canonical
Tosca G is on the licen creed background
and we do see about 60 65 percent
penetrant into microglia and we'll
address that in momentarily that that
point momentarily but we can quantify
this data and we can show that in the
red box is here deficient efficiency and
lap leads to just a massive exacerbation
of amyloid deposition and in this case
we're measuring it by total plaque
number so this still doesn't answer the
question of whether it's actually
lapping microglia right and using the
licen cream model we do have penetrants
and we do see an effect however it's
still not answering if this is a
microglia specific function of lap so
what we decided to do is use an elegant
model that is driven by CX PCR one cream
tamoxifen inducible where we actually
weaned animals and we start the
tamoxifen injection protocol and we stop
tamoxifen injection by day five and we
allow these mice to H in this case out
to four months again but once you hit 30
days we have a microglia specific
deletion the peripheral monocytes that
are targeted by cx-3 cr1 have been
reconstituted from the bone marrow and
restored expression what hopefully you
can garner from this Western blot is
that if we look at the primary microglia
from these cells now these are four
months old mice you can see that there
is a nice complete knockout of 200 or
rubicon for a lap or a kapha T
respectively in primary microglia
however those genes have been expression
goes genes and proteins have been fully
restored in peripheral macrophages here
from screaming macrophages so the
question then we asked the same question
what happens with amyloid deposition and
like we saw previously we start to have
a little amyloid deposition in either
the control mice or those that are
deficient in canonical etaf adji in the
microbial compartment but there's really
no difference between those two however
if we abrogate laughs in the microbial
compartment shown on the bottom right we
can see again a massive exacerbation in
the deposition of amyloid and
hippocampus of these animals
so we know that we're having more
neurotoxic amyloid presence in these
these mice that are deficient either in
lap or lap specifically in microbial
cells but not those that are deficient
at Apogee so we next ask the question
does this deposition of amyloid lead to
this microglial activation and the
reactive microglia is characterized in
human Alzheimer's disease do we see the
same thing in the animal model and again
if we look at those mice that are just
deficient in a kapha G we see very
little micro glial activation and we're
basically at and we're asking that here
by measuring IV a1 expression and IV a 1
as a marker protein for microglial cells
it's basically expressed and it's
expressions drastically increased upon
activation and we see this basal
staining of iba 1 at least these mice at
4 months of age however again in the
animals that have massive deposition of
amyloid those are deficient in the LAT
pathway now we see a very robust
activation of these microbial cells by
IV a once staining and if we take that a
step further and we actually look at the
morphology of the cell it's not just
that they have IBA one but we actually
see if these cells are going from that
ramified resting state to that amoeboid
activated state we can see sure enough
that mice that are deficient in lap have
a very amoeboid morphology of their
microglial cells and again we can
quantify that by actually representing
it as the percentage of loss if you will
of ramified microglia per field and what
we can see is that there's a higher
propensity for those microglia cells to
be amoeboid in morphology so that's all
fine and good so we have active
activated microglia that are that are
down this activated in one like
phenotype but the real question then is
do they actually produce inflammatory
cytokines which is the key to labeling
these is a reactive microbiotic
phenotype and if we look at Mike excuse
me the hippocampus of these animals the
measured pro-inflammatory cytokines in
this region what we see is that those in
green and blue bars that are deficient
in the LAT pathway have a massive up
regulation of TNF alpha il-1 il-6 and
CCL 5 so we have pro-inflammatory
cytokine production that is being being
up
resonated in these animals
so that led us to this idea of we know
in a human disease model if we have
these inflammatory cytokines in this
amyloid deposition that typically leads
to the hyper phosphorylation of a
protein that's called tau how isn't
micro state microtubule stabilizing
protein found in neurons it's very
important for neuronal function and and
synapse integrity and we know in human
disease that as disease progresses you
have more and more of this
phosphorylated tau and that leads to the
destabilization of microtubules and
ultimately loss of synapses and axonal
degeneration so if we take these mice
again and we look at those that are
deficient in their top adji versus those
livers efficient in both pathways we can
see that there's very little
phosphorylation of tau however if we
take out lap now and again this can be
done in globally or in microglia
specifically it's a microglia specific
phenotype what we see is a drastic
drastic up regulation of tau
phosphorylation and throughout the
entire hippocampus and this can be
recapitulated in the the cortex as well
secuence of that type of phosphorus now
again as I mentioned is this idea of
neuronal degeneration so if we take a
region of the hippocampus that's called
the ca3 region and this is the
presynaptic region the hippocampus is
thought to be involved in regulating
memory of memory loss excuse me when
their own loss in this region in all
fiber stations if we take that region
and we stain for neuronal nuclear
neuronal nuclei marker for neurons and
we also Costain for cleave caspase-3 for
adopt otic cells what we can see is that
when we have mice that are deficient and
lap on the bottom panel the rubicon
decision animals in these brains in the
CIPA Kampai we see that there's a
significant staining fork leave
caspase-3 that is in the neuronal
compartment suggesting we have actual
neuro degeneration occurring so we can
quantify that and sure enough we see
that that with lap deletion we have this
increase in presynaptic neurone will
death now while that is all fine and
good suggestive neuro degeneration it
still does not fully suggest that we
have an impairment of function so what
we really decide to do first before we
get to the functional assay was to just
profile the total number of neurons
within the hippocampus for these animals
and what we saw basically correlated
nicely to our Cleef caspase-3 staining
in the fact that these animals that are
deficient in the LAT pathway have a
significant reduction in the number of
neurons within the hippocampus and you
can clearly see that here with the
asterisk present on the graph so we know
that we have what we presume to be neuro
degeneration because we have a loss of
neuronal number that are a plus the
cleave caspase-3 staining suggesting
apoptosis but does that have a
functional consequence and the answer to
that is yes and we did this in
collaboration with with the neurobiology
lab and response lab here at st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital and a big
component with done by dr. Brett Talmer
a colleague of mine and what he showed
was if we do electro physiology of the
hippocampus in these animals and again
the ones with the open open legend
they're those animals are deficient in
lap and we can see that there's a
significant impairment in synaptic
transmission so they're not effectively
sending a signal across
those synapses from the ca3 to the ca1
region of the hippocampus and as a
consequence of that they're unable to
have long-term potentiation so basically
the reef iring of these neurons to keep
signaling going and strengthening that
connection which leads to memory
so that brought us to utilizing three
well-known behavioral tests in animals
the first one is sucrose preference test
measures anhedonia or the inability to
feel pleasure which is a which is often
a complaint in severe severe Alzheimer's
patients and then the other two the why
maze and the novel object recognition
for memory analysis and as we would
expect we would we would hope we would
see what we do see and we did we saw a
massive massive impairment not only in
the ability to sense pleasure with the
superest preference test but also the
memory deficit that occurs in these mice
that are lap deficient with either the y
maes analysis or the novel object
recognition just massive impairment in
their ability to perform in these tests
and again that was at this point it's a
drastic phenotype but it's almost
expected because of the fact we have
neuronal death we have decreased neuron
number we have impairment of
electrophysiology and function of those
neurons so this was not too surprising
even though it is so dramatic of a
phenotype
so to summarize thus far what I want to
what I really want to want to show is
that first of all in this animal model
we have basically tick the boxes of all
of the major components of at least
hallmarks of human Alzheimer's disease
including amyloid pathology including
reactive microglia system neuro
inflammation including hyper
phosphorylation of tau including neuro
degeneration and then ultimately to
behavior and memory impairment that goes
in hand with that one aspect that I do
need to point out that we have not been
able to recapitulate that is consistent
with human disease is the tangling of
tau protein which is something we're
still investigating currently so to
summarize thus far what I've told you is
that Rubicon and other Lap regulators in
microglia seem to be protective against
not only amyloid deposition but also tau
pathology neuro inflammation and
ultimately neuro degeneration I've also
shown you that the impairment of the
obligation of Ouray tg5 or Rubicon will
lead to dramatic exacerbation of AV
phenotype and this appears to be a
microglia specific function of this
pathway and the abrogation of canonical
esophageal microglia does not alter the
pathology in these deep animal models
so what I want to want to really want to
ask next is we we ask the question what
is the actual mechanism of this right we
see this massive phenotype but why is it
occurring and how is it occurring so a
hint came from a very talented postdoc
it was in the lab a few years ago and
she was one that really drove laughs
into the forefront and she showed a few
things including a lot of the immune
regulation of lap and that's dr.
Jennifer Martinez who now has her own
program at the NIH and what she showed
is that lap actually impedes phagosome
maturation or disk using the in addition
of lap actually impede phagosome
maturation and ultimately clearance of
that phagocytic cargo as you can see
here in the ATG 7 position cells so we
hypothesized that that was probably the
result that was what was the resultant
factor and why we see this master the
extracellular accumulation of amyloid
when lap is deficient we thought for
sure that these microglia cells would
basically internalize these a beta
particles but then insufficiently be
able to clear them because of lap
similar to what Jennifer showed with
these dying cells and when we did the
assay we see that the regardless of just
genotype these microbial cells not only
internalize the amyloid but they also
clear the amyloid perfectly fine so it
appears that lap deficiency in this this
context is not impaired amyloid uptake
or clearance which was which was
shocking to us so we took it another
step further and we looked at the actual
acidification of the vesicle so not just
can they clear it but are the vesicles
actually you know becoming mature or is
this some other phenotype that we just
have not explained yet so if you see on
the left side this is pH roto lingual
rynason so it's a pH sensitive died for
us and died and what we can see is that
when those those vesicles containing
this phagocytic substrate diagnosan that
we know is regulated by lap in-lap
deficiency there's a failure for these
cells receiving for these phagosome to
mature and you can see that here they're
clearly not getting the same level of
acidification as those that are either
parental microglia or v 2 which are at
avijit deficient microglia in comparison
if we label pH roto on amyloid particles
and we do the same experiment now all
the sudden we
not see a failure to acidify these
vesicles that contain amyloid regardless
of lap deficiency or lapse efficiency
there they're perfectly able to acidify
so I took it another step further and we
asked the question is there co
localization of these vegetables with
the lysosomal protein linked one and
again consistent with the previous data
we saw that in the context of the
phagocytic lab substrate Simonsen there
is an impaired co-localization with lamp
one suggesting a decreased maturation
and those vegetables that contained
analyte no such impairment they were
perfectly fine they were able to make it
to the lysosome and ultimately the
content degraded so we asked the
question are we really confident or we
just acting like we know what's going on
we thought it was lap and we asked the
question is it really laughs so what we
did next is we just did a very missing
rough and dirty experiment where we take
the f-actin inhibitor of the trunk
elands this prevents f-actin assembly
which is required for canonical
phagocytosis as well as lap and we we
looked at phagocytic time are phagocytic
substrate Simonsen vs. are an acidic
substrate dextran and we can clearly see
here that Letran kealin is working
nicely and it does not affect in the
cytosis so what about amyloid what we
found was quite shocking to us in the
fact that we saw that it appears that
amyloid at least amyloid one 2:42
oligomers is behaving very similar to in
acidic substrate dextran and not to our
phagocytic substrate zionism and if we
take it a step further and we decided to
image these cells and see if we could
find co-localization between lc3 on the
membrane of these vesicles containing
amyloid as well as other markers for
receptor meaning they're cytosis
including clathrin as well as RAB v and
we see that indeed both of these both of
these markers co-localize very nicely
with LC 3 and these vesicles containing
amyloid and this was not only what we
saw but other groups and including a
recent paper have shown that indeed this
February and oligomeric amyloid one 2:42
peptide is actually mediated through a
class or independent mechanism which was
but
also unique finding and confirmed like I
said by others so this was very unique
that we saw this and is very exciting
what we saw because it described a new
pathway and what these needed these data
actually suggest is they suggest there's
a new function for lc3 and endocytosis
and so we we ended up naming the pathway
lc3 associated endocytosis but that
still does not ask the question answer
the question that we had originally and
that is why does the inability to
conjugate lc3 to now the in the zonal
compartment exacerbate amyloid
deposition right
we still need to answer that fundamental
question so what we did is we found a
paper by a Toni Weiss carré's group
where he actually shows that one of
these proteins again involved in the
pathway back when one it regulates the
rectum or trafficking of receptors
required for for for amyloid recognition
and ultimately they're impaired in
Alzheimer's disease so we use an assay
I'm not going to describe its receptor
recycling assay this is our version of
it it's very similar to the version used
by Tony and his lab as well as multiple
other labs and what we're looking at
here in these images you'll see in just
a moment we're actually looking at rhe
internalized receptor after it's
recycled so it's a cytosolic signal but
all of the receptor we're going to be
seeing has been recycled and what we saw
was if we take ourselves at again are
deficient in lamp what we see is that
whether we're looking at tlr4 trend 2 or
CD 36 all putative amyloid receptors we
can see that in parental cells or those
deficient for 1500 or canonical
esophageal there's really no impairment
of recycling we cells recycle the
receptor very nicely however if we
delete the genes required for now lando
we can see that those those those cells
have a significant reduction in
recycling of those three particular
receptors and we can also quantify that
and you can see that it's not a full
impairment but it is a very significant
reduction in recycling in bb2 microglial
cells this is also is also able to be
recapitulated in primary microglial
cells as you can see here in Rubicon
deficient cells from Rubicon knockout
animals they have a significant
reduction in recycling of trim to
so we decided to implement what we call
a secondary amyloid uptick acid that we
developed to be able to really see if
this was was a consequence of something
and why it would lead to the extra
cellular accumulation of amyloid and
what we saw like we've seen previously
the first exposure of these microbial
cells to amyloid there was no difference
in the uptake and this was this was
expected however what we saw is if we
take those cells and weari challenge
them at a later time point with in this
case we just used a different color -
amyloid for imaging purposes and for
analysis by flow what we see is that
sure enough now cells in the green and
the blue bars that are deficient in
Lando requirement students require genes
for Lando we can see that now there is
an impaired secondary uptake so they
have a decrease in the uptake so that
could be attributed to this decreased
recycling of the receptors that are
required to recognize that ambulant on
the plasma membrane so the model that
we've developed through this is we know
the neuro toxic amyloid is extracellular
and what we see is in a microglia that
is sufficient in the land of a pathway
they're able to internalize that amyloid
and efficiently degrade it and receptors
for those those 3 receptors that we
showed that are putative receptor for
amyloid are able to recycle nicely to
the plasma membrane and can subsequently
recognize more and more amyloid in
contrast cells that microbial cells are
deficient in Lando can it can recognize
amyloid and internalize it as well as
degrade it however they have an impaired
recycling of those receptors and they're
not able to recognize at least as much
amyloid in future or subsequent rounds
of ligation and uptick and we think that
contributes to this extracellular
accumulation of amyloid that we observe
in the mouse
so what I want to really highlight real
quickly and a couple other pieces of
data are the future directions of this
research and we really need to determine
the mechanistic regulation of lap versus
lando because they seem to use the same
genetic machinery and the same component
and currently the only way we can
delineate them is from a cell biology
standpoint in terms of what compartment
lc3 is being conjugated to whether it's
phagosome Zoar endosomes we also want to
answer the question is how does Lana
actually regulate or influence this
inflammatory activation we know that if
we abrogate lando we have a massive
increase in inflammatory response but
why and how does that occur we also want
to know taking this outside of the
context of this neurodegeneration and
ask the Pascal Lando and Turner
Associated microglia might regulate the
inflammatory environment of the brain
tumor and then also how can we
specifically target Lando's a
therapeutic approach for treating
conditions that have a component of
neural inflammation
so on the first point of this this idea
of delineating the mechanistic
regulation of lando we have some data
that suggested it is a 100% dependent
process on LC 3 and what we can see here
is again looking at receptor recycling
for tlr4 trim 2 and CD 36 we can see
that when we abrogate else the ability
for LC 3 to be conjugated to those into
zomes to either using Rav Z which is a
protease that cleaves lipid ated LC 3 or
dominant negative ATG 4 which prevents
the Assembly of LC 3 onto those pi/3 p
residues those PA 3 p lipid species we
can see the receptor recycling is
impaired so it appears to be an lc3
dependent process and we also know that
the again if we look at components of
the etosha gene machinery that
components such as ATP 587 the kinase v
PS 34 all required and if you a brigade
those their function you decrease
recycling however components of the
initiation complex in red are totally
dispensable for the process so what
we've done in the recent steps if we try
to you know really come up with a
screening assay if we can actually make
this into a high-throughput screen for a
genetic screen for example to try and
find novel regulators of these pathways
and using a new new imaging base screen
and this
hopefully be adapted into the flow
cytometry world shortly we can see that
we can actually analyze the reefs
accretion of transferrin in this case
and we can see that wild-type cells
nicely two reefs accrete transparent and
they drop their interest so they're
transparent content after a pulse chase
assay whereas those that are deficient
in Lando retain transparent
intracellularly so we've been able to
use this and we've had a few hits from
this and unfortunately we're not quite
ready to share the target itself but we
do have a putative target that you can
see here when we delete it it totally
impairs the recycling of in this case
tlr4 however one is reconstituted as
microglial cells we're able to restore
functions so we're hoping this could be
a putative delineation between the Lapp
pathway and the Lando pathway in the
near future and hopefully we will be
able to publish that at some point so
when we compare lap and lander what we
know thus far as we know that both laugh
and Lando require rubicon we know that
laugh requires reactive oxygen species
we don't think Lando does but we don't
know for sure yet it's not been formally
tested we also know that both laugh and
Lando have a distinct pi3 kinase complex
that is unique this is different from
maitake we also know that lap promotes
vesicle maturation and ultimately
lysosomal fusion but we do not think
Lando actually has an effect there since
we see no change in Ambilight up taker
or or amyloid clearance in these
microbial cells so what's the function
of LC 3 in the context of this Lando
pathway is still to be understood if
it's not facilitating vesicle maturation
we know that Lando facilitates receptor
recycling we don't necessarily think lab
has a role there because it's ultimately
going to the lysosome for degradation
and we know that both pathways seem to
regulate inflammatory immune activation
but again until we have a genetic
delineation between them it's going to
be hard to really quantify which one
contributes more which one is actually
contributing depending on the setting so
what I want to summarize with the very
end here is that Lando is a unique
molecular pathways functions and not
only neural information and receptor
recycling but also neuro degeneration
and from new data that we're garnering
every day we think this is going to be a
very broad process that could be
relevant to a whole host of not only
cell by
processes but also to a variety of
conditions and diseases so on that note
I really have to thank everybody that
was involved in this project for the lab
here including a our laboratory leader
green as well as our lab manager Pat
Fitzgerald for just facilitating this
work fully and providing all the
resources necessary internal
collaborators here at st. Jude of course
I have to say my funding directly from
the National Institute MS constitutes of
health here in the US as well as the
John H Sununu foundation for my
endowment and of course to Middleton e
biotech for the invitation to present
today and on that note I would be more
than happy to take any questions thank
you very much
Thank You Bradley for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask the question and click on
the send button
Babli will answer as many questions as
time permits ok our first question is a
two-part question the first part is are
there changes in Rubicon or a PG 5
expression in the brains of human
Alzheimer's patients that's an excellent
question and like I mentioned at the
very beginning of the the presentation
we do know that the expression of these
Ataka G genes does change typically with
age and in certain certain groups of
decreases typically aged individuals
have lower expression with respect to
Rubicon there's not a lot of data out
there right now that suggests that
Rubicon actually you know decreases too
much with age that being said we do know
proteins such as 85 and 87 are decreased
typically as we age and then ultimately
decrease more in the context of an
Alzheimer's patient
right now the second part of this
question are there any known snips or
other disease associated genetic
abnormalities sure sure so that's a
really really interesting question it's
a very one that I get a lot when I
present this work so with regard to
Alzheimer's disease we know that you
know the major genetic components like a
bowi
in modular abnormalities and a phony as
well as amyloid precursor protein and
the different secret ace families are
well characterized in Alzheimer's
disease that being said with respect to
ATG 587 Rubicon for example we'd have no
known snips or or mutations in those
particular particular genes that
correlates our Alzheimer's disease
besides the changes in expression we do
know that there are subsets of mutations
in in Rubicon for example that are rare
but they have been shown to cause a
variety of neurological deficits
including cerebral ataxia so these be
you know these particular mutations
could really lead to a real massive loss
of function what I really think is
occurring in the context of of Rubicon
for example or ATG 5 is that in you know
we don't I don't think Alzheimer's
patients have a total deficiency of
lando or lap for that matter I think
they have a an abrogation of function to
a point where this this process or the
inability to complete this process acts
as a second hit if you will such as the
two-hit hypothesis in cancer
great thank you okay next question how
does decreased receptor recycling
increase inflammatory immune signaling
and is it simply to to increase
extracellular amyloid sure so that's
also a very nice question and I think
the the real idea here is that we we
don't know the answer there's a short
the short answer to that what we think
is occurring is it could be due to
extrasolar amyloid accumulation
activating receptors such as CD 36 or in
particular tlr4 and basically continue a
continuing signaling path if you will
but what we actually think might be
occurring that could actually impact the
inflammatory activation more is if we
have internalization of let's say
activated ligated tlr4 into the cell
into the microglial cell we know that
that tlr4 eventually under normal
circumstances would be recycled and that
signal would be a finite signal but what
we think is occurring is if those
recycling events are impaired then that
provides more time for intracellular
tlr4 that's been internalized basically
to function in to signal to the nucleus
to activate pathways such as NF kappa-b
and maintain that inflammatory signaling
however that's going to take some more
work to really delineate that process
thank you is Lando restricted to immune
cells such as microglia and macrophages
sure so I think you know here's the
thing with when we look at laps for
example I'll see three associated
phagocytosis this process is from the
most part restricted to professional
phagocytes macrophages dendritic cells
etc in comparison we know we know that
Lando is now functioning in microglia we
also know that it functions in
macrophages such as macrophage cell
lines such as our ma cell line but we
also now have data that shows that Lando
and the reset list receptor recycling
phenotype of Lando is functioning in a
you know mouse embryonic fibroblast as
well as HeLa cells so it appears that
Lando is going to be much more similar
to canonical esophageal in the context
of its broad usage if you will by
different cell types and of course we we
will we'll need to pursue that further
to really understand the function of it
in different cell types but it's likely
to have an important function across the
board
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question is Lando specific for
the recycling of amyloid receptors or
our other receptors affected by the
abrogation of Lando yeah so this is this
is a good point and it's it's extremely
important obviously for the relevance of
biology so what we've tested obviously
in the paper and what I showed you today
was was three receptors that are
putative for amyloid recognition tlr4 CD
36 and of course come to the major one
you know we've also interrogated other
receptors and we found a few that are
seem to have no relevance to Lando that
their recycling is totally independent
and we've also found receptors including
a you know menos receptor for example
that appear to also be influenced by
Landa so it does not seem that it's a
strictly process that is governing these
three receptors with those that are
required for Alzheimer's disease but
more likely it's probably not a
ubiquitous process in terms of every
receptor in an organism but it will
likely be a subset of receptors but well
beyond just the three that we've
described here
you
I would like to once again thank Bradley
for his time today and his important
research I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and further
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor milk and biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand laborat alert you when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event until
next time goodbye